what kind of noises do you make when I
when I bus I'm a pretty I don't know I
don't know that I'm very I I'll grunt I
suppose I I haven't really thought about
it I mean do you ever quiet do I ever
quiet are you
quiet what do you mean I I do quiet
style like when I come I purposely don't
say anything what some kind of nin I'll
yeah I'll look in the eyes assassin
thing
go like you're committing sepu yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and they're always
like you know what mean like they look
at me like what the [__] is happening
stroke yeah exactly should try that 52y
old man no no because old and fat NE
neither of us can do it what neither one
of us can I can't be quietly coming
people I didn't they'll think I'm having
a heart attack like oh [__] he's about
to die inside of me so you do make a
noise